guys like hear that you're bi is a girl
yes
of course it's like oh you want to have
a threesome oh my god i'm not a unicorn
we brought together seven bisexuals i
am bisexual i am bisexual i'm bisexual
i am bisexual i'm bisexual i'm bisexual
i
am bisexual one is a liar
if the group discovers who the liar is
they'll split a cash prize
if the liar survives they win the entire
prize
who is the odd one out
okay okay what's up i'm david nice to
meet you
tristan marissa i'm sydney ellie melvin
molly i was nervous because everyone was
looking like they could fit into
being a bisexual person how would you
define bisexuality in like your own
words i guess
for me it's just being attracted to
human beings where i see people for
their heart and their soul
of course i care about the outside too
don't get me wrong i was suspicious of
david just because that was the closest
one i
could feel was not bisexual david just
has more of a hetero look compared to
everyone else
i've dated both girls and guys not that
that means like you're bi or not
i see it as a fluidity sometimes i'm
like more into men more into women but
no matter what it's not a passing phase
i'm always going to be
bisexual no matter who i'm dating for me
the same thing basically it's just i
don't really have a
preference i recently saw on tick tock
someone say being bi could be
being attracted to people who are
non-binary
and yeah very gender-wise and i'm like
you know what i kind of like that even
better because i feel like that's more
inclusive
i felt like molly was like very sure of
herself so that made me a little
suspicious
it close to pansexual it's kind of the
same because we are trying to both
gender but sometimes
[Music]
my gut instincts were telling me ellie
might be
the odd one out
i felt like i should vote for molly
because i feel like this is the safe bet
and we have a tie between ellie
and molly that means we're going into a
tie breaker
what we're gonna do is give you each 20
seconds
to state your case okay i don't know
what to tell you guys
maybe i came off this drug or something
but i just have a big personality
i am bisexual i've questioned it
multiple times beforehand
but i finally identified what i really
feel
and i mean i hope you guys can see that
all right i have known that i was bi or
not straight or a lesbian since i was
about
eight years old when my parents caught
me looking up girls kissing on youtube
angelica from rugrats is what really
started this off for me
so that's pretty gay
so i think molly her answers at the end
when she was like trying to prove
herself were too spot on
this is definitely like very
stereotypical
yeah my radar's off right now
[Music]
if i'm wrong i question my judgment
i mean like i know myself like i knew
how to present myself because it's
me and i am bisexual but i think being
myself
sounded too rehearsed what kind of music
do you listen like what artists do
listen
to selena gomez
[Applause]
so like my last name online is glambert
everywhere and if that's not kind of gay
i don't know what it is i listen to
beyonce
i was suspicious of melvin at first and
the mole could also be someone who's
more of like a feminine man
i have a question yes okay so when did
everyone came out and how was the
family reaction friend's reaction was
like my parents like my mom i can't
i was like the first time taking it
edible or having a moment i'm like mom i
need to tell you something and she's
like what and i'm like
i like girls what do you guys do and
she's just like oh okay and like no one
really expected it but everyone's really
accepting i feel like because
sometimes i'll be like with a guy more
than like people question oh are you
actually bisexual or not so i questioned
it multiple times
once like sophomore junior college i
felt like i could identify
with bisexuality so to me i came out
when i graduated high school i was like
feminine like the way i worked where i
talk and everything and i was like okay
well i guess i'm gay and then
found a girl i was like well i'm
straight um
i actually like both so i guess i'm back
i came out as
lesbian in eighth grade and then in
ninth grade realized that i liked a guy
do you tend to like dick guys more or
less now i have but i like used to date
girls more and then i started dating but
i mean i date both but yeah
she knew what she was saying but there
wasn't that strong of an emotional
connection coming out through her face
she sounded like someone who did
research on like bisexuality i'm
wondering like what are some of them
dumb stereotypes you guys have heard
that like are really annoying to you
like your pet peeves that were cheaters
yeah oh my god yeah to me it's like oh
you buy so
you can't just get everyone yeah many of
your partners ever said like oh more
competition
hello it's like no like i love you
you know exactly although i have dated a
guy and a girl at the same time once it
didn't go well
but for once i felt like people were
validating me because you were actually
actioned like actually exactly oh yeah
now what am i gay or am i straight to
you because i have both
yeah exactly i think it's also annoying
when like guys like hear
that you're bi is a girl and of course
it's like oh
you want to have a threesome oh my god
i'm not a unicorn
like seriously the first question you
always get asked at least for like i
know for women too it's like well have
you even been with a girl
for men it's always like you're not
bisexual you're gay if people ask me
like oh do you like girls or guys more
yeah i don't want to answer that
question because it always changes like
you said
i've only dated guys but it doesn't mean
i'm gay
i still am attracted to woman and it's
like and the thing is like they're
assumed that
you're gay but you know you just think
that you buy just to make it like easier
yeah are you sure you're just not gay
and yeah just try something
and i feel like it's way worse for guys
in that way and then for girls it's like
no you're just straight
so i voted for sydney because i don't
know she seemed a little nervous
i honestly really don't know i was a
little more suspicious of ellie because
i also felt like the guys were kind of
teaming up so i wanted to vote for her
so i wouldn't be voted out
i'm so sorry
[Music]
it's okay i hope you find the hetero
guys
i was just so confused why they chose me
maybe i was talking too much
i don't know everyone was too quiet so i
had to i felt like i had to speak up
if you want to continue playing please
raise your hand
in three two one
i have a question okay was it difficult
for you to come out to yourself
because it was extremely difficult for
me because i never really had a crush on
a guy because i would only have crushes
on females like i remember it was right
after graduate high school i was doing
research on sexuality you know the
spectrum and everything
you take the quiz that you're like i
took like 100 i took 100 quizzes
even now i still have moments where i'm
like uh
like what am i but i feel confident
saying i'm bi you know but
yeah i think it was hard for me like i
mentioned before like more to myself
than like my family or the people around
me
but it was just challenging figuring
that out i'm sorry i have doubt on you
same i'm time
so because i voted for sydney twice i
had to call her out in the middle of the
game
melvin like pointed me out as being
suspicious
now everyone's gonna vote for me oh my
god i don't know what to ask like i just
do you guys have like a favorite tv
character like representation
yeah i would say uh because i'm being
called out on alice from the l word
i was on an episode of the l word as an
lgbt like background person
i started the first gsa at my middle
school i don't know what else to do
and she tried to defend herself but it
was not convincing to me
i don't like to ask like okay when he's
pride monks
show like they think about stereotypes i
feel like i'm very feminine so like that
would be so easy for me to just be
straight
that's fair that's fair yeah i was
suspicious of sydney but then there was
a point where i was also suspicious of
melvin
the fact that he did go against sydney
that made me
think about it a little you guys i'm
really telling the truth
oh my god this is so hard
so in round three i began maybe doubting
myself a little bit thinking okay it
could be sydney
[Music]
so i was like it's either gonna be me or
marissa i thought the guys would like
vote against the girls because two girls
were voted out in the first two rounds
[Music]
you guys messed up i was so sad because
i really liked everyone i trusted
everyone at that point so it sucked but
i was also expecting it
if everyone feels confident that you
guys cut them all you guys can end the
game here
please raise your hand if you want to
continue the game in three
two one
if it's you oh wait
i mean he did have a good intuition i
feel like if the lights turn green that
means
and you lose
i was so nervous in the beginning that i
was going to get voted out first so i
was so happy
when i made it to the end feels like i'm
in the right place that's where i wanted
to be
will the mall please step forward and
reveal yourself
in three two one
[Applause]
i'm not bisexual i'm actually straight
i think a lot of people found difficulty
in figuring out who was bisexual they
didn't really have a tactic
you can't really tell who's bisexual
based on just looking at them or
whatever
i like men even though i think they're
trash but
what you
to be bisexual is to just love who you
want to love
it's to be attracted to male female and
they can go a little bit beyond
more doors being open that's how i see
[Music]
bisexuality